good afternoon is everybody ready for
the best accessibility i/o ever right on
right on my name is Brian Kemmler I'm a
p.m. on Android accessibility our goal
is to ensure that everyone can use our
products no matter what their ability
specifically we design and build
accessibility suite sound amplifier live
transcribe and now live caption we've
invested heavily in the last year to
make audio on Android much more
accessible so we'll be focusing a lot on
that today here with me today are
Melissa Lauren and Kelly our passionate
team of researchers programmers and and
engineers today I'm going to share my
expect 'iv on accessibility 'z mission
and why it matters I'll discuss new
products for the deaf and hard of
hearing melissa will show you how we'll
use structured research to inform our
most important product making decisions
lastly Kelly and Lauren are going to
talk about new products for users with
physical disabilities reduce dexterity
low vision and blindness so now let's
talk about our mission accessibility
mission is integral to Google's so
integral it's in the mission statement
itself to make the world's information
universally accessible and useful let's
unpack that a little bit universally
accessible means everyone can use
Android we don't expect users to adapt
our products rather we adapt our
products to our users because we think
of accessibility as a human right if
there are barriers for anyone we have
more work to do and it's with this
mantra that we design build and apply
Google magic to make both our products
and the real world around us more
accessible and more useful for more
users in more
situations the world's information means
it's not just about making what's on the
device accessible but it's about making
the planet more accessible and to do
this we apply advances in machine
learning and artificial intelligence
what I call the Google magic to meet the
needs of underserved communities last
February we launched live transcribe an
accessibility first experience enabling
any anyone to have a conversation
without feedback allowing anyone to have
a conversation even if they can't hear
you can think of live transcribe as
captioning for the real world sound
amplifier and look out are also great
examples of building accessibility first
experiences and you could think of this
overall approach as a practice practical
useful and potentially transformative
application of augmented reality so why
is this important why do we care many of
us in fact including myself at one point
in time believed that disability was
something that only affected a small set
of the population even in the strictest
sense that set is massive it's a billion
people or 15 percent of the world's
population but let's start to think
about disability a little more
holistically so if we include people who
don't self-identify as having a
disability this number one billion it
doubles it grows if we think of friends
family and loved ones of folks who have
disabilities well then that number grows
again and thinking of this even more
expansively if we think about disability
to include people with temporary
conditions like a broken arm or a broken
leg or situational ones like driving and
texting don't do it then our circle
expands to include nearly the entire
planet so it's really everyone's work to
make not just our products but the
planet more accessible
and when we do so we're affirming that
accessibility is a human right so apart
from doing the right thing I'm going to
talk to you a little bit today about why
there are some very positive karmic
consequences when we design for
accessibility first so much so a term
was coined for it and that term is the
curb cut effect so you see back in the
day there were no curb cut just as at
one point in time there were no closed
captions so that meant that people who
use wheelchairs effectively encountered
a wall every time they came to to a curb
so in 1945 there was a guy in Kalamazoo
Michigan named Jack Fisher who was
disabled and he advocated and fought for
the installation of the country's first
curb cut and they caught on globally
sidewalks and more importantly cities
became independently navigable for the
very first time and this had positive
consequences literally for everyone for
parents with kids and strollers or
people toting luggage for workers with
dollies or hand hand trucks and now
today we can't even imagine a world
without them because we're much safer
and it's much easier to get along to get
around and this is what was dubbed the
curb cut effect another realization of
the curb cut effect is closed captions
personally I love captions they're great
for the World Series or the World Cup at
a at a loud bar they let me listen in
silence when I'm on the train or at the
library or I don't want to bother my
coworkers as awesome as they are for me
they're game-changing for the four
hundred and sixty-six million people on
the planet who have hearing loss so
about a year ago we prototyped and built
an accessibility first application
called live transcribe and we launched
it in February I'm gonna switch over and
do a little demo of live transcribe
demo yep great so so this is nothing
special this is a basic Android
smartphone as you can tell I'm just
speaking naturally and quickly and it's
picking everything up in real time it
works in over 70 languages and it's a
great tool or a great bridge to carry
around with you in your in your pocket
if you need to transcribe a conversation
it's amazing it also captures very
subtle nuances so I can say something
such as I bought in New Jersey in New
Jersey and it doesn't work for the demo
but I usually say it and I usually say I
bought a New Jersey in New Jersey
well it doesn't like it it usually gets
context but the demo gods are not
forgiving today it also has a great
feature which we call tight pack so if
you prefer not to speak or in case you
can't speak you can type a response back
to the person speaking right here in the
interface so it's really more of a
two-way conversation tool than it is
strictly strictly captions awesome my
demo didn't work back to the slides
please so now that we literally have
captions in the real world what's the
next frontier for captions so I'm super
glad you asked on let's turn to the
growth of online video and build empathy
for people who are missing out on this
explosion of content so every minute 400
hours a video of being uploaded to
YouTube so we saw that this was a
problem and in 2009 we added automated
captions to all the content on YouTube
which was an awesome awesome first start
but what about personal videos social
media podcasts you know the stuff that
we love to use each and every day
they're typically uncaptioned meaning
for the deaf and hard-of-hearing it's
effectively a silent movie
so led by the
Creative Lab in New York who is here
today we started exploring a simple
question could we automatically caption
any media playing across her phone so
together with a whole bunch of teams
from Mountain View in New York and Tel
Aviv and speech research and the
creative lab and audio framework and
accessibility we banded together and we
spent a year trying to solve this
problem and so I'm gonna let the result
live captions speak for itself
and switch over to the demo
so I'm using Google photos and this is
nothing special here it's a video of my
cat and my fiance and a little message
that they've recorded for me hi honey
hope you're having a great time at i/o
we miss you so much Tico misses you hope
you're having a great time so you can
see I can caption anything anything on
the device and it went away let me bring
it back hi honey
hope you're having a great time at i/o
we miss you so much
Tico misses you hope you're having a
great time
hi honey hope you're having a great time
at i/o we miss you so that's live
caption and it works with podcasts it
works with videos that you record voice
mail or instant messaging apps on video
and so forth and we're super excited you
may have seen that we mentioned it in
the in the keynotes today what you see
there is literally just the tip of the
iceberg so we use recurrent neural
networks that we've shrunk down from
these monster models that used to run in
the cloud and we run them locally on the
device and that gives that gives us some
really cool advantages so one it lets
the product work offline so I can be in
a totally offline mode I can be in a
plane it's going to work to audio never
goes up to the clouds so it just sits
there locally and best of all developers
and content providers never need to lift
a finger if there's audio there are
captions so with live caption every app
billions of videos and podcasts from any
any source are one step closer to being
universally accessible on Android now
over to Melissa to talk about how we use
research to inform our most important
product making decisions
Thank You Bryan hi everyone my name is
Melissa Barnhart and I'm a researcher on
Android and today I'd like to talk to
you about the user experience so when
you think about the user experience I'd
like you to think about empathy empathy
is at the heart of design without the
understanding of what others see feel
and experience design is a pointless
task and to be empathetic technologists
we have to set aside our own assumptions
and consider other perspectives now a
great way to build empathy is through
user research user research focuses on
understanding behaviors and needs
through a variety of methodologies like
interviews observations or survey just
to name a few like a compass user
research can help point you and your
product in the right direction and you
can utilize user research at any stage
in your design and development process
before you begin building user research
can uncover an unmet needs and inspire
designs that actually meet those needs
the number one reason for startup
failure is lack of market need for a
product but you can minimize this risk
by conducting research before
development even begins
and when development is underway user
research can help you evaluate different
design solutions and ensure that your
user experience stays on track and then
when your product is out in the market
you can use research to help measure the
impact of your designs and also to show
the ROI so today I'd like to share an
example of how we've used user research
to improve live transcribe a new Android
application that provides real-time
transcription for the deaf and
hard-of-hearing a team of research
scientists at Google identified a new
opportunity for automatic speech
recognition and built the first
prototype for live transcribe so we have
the technology but what about the user
experience we had a lot of questions
about live transcribed that we hope to
address through research with the deaf
and hard of hearing participants for
example what are their first impressions
of live transcribe also how would they
expect scrolling to work in both
landscape and portrait orientations
should it scroll from top to bottom
should it kind of fade away or should it
resemble a physical book but our most
pressing question was about the visual
design what font style type form text
size text color and background colors
should we default to we assumed that
users would want to see differently
colored confidence levels to indicate
the accuracy of the transcription but we
didn't know for sure and good research
starts with good research questions like
these ones so to answer our research
questions we took a mixed methods
approach we started with a usability
study in a Google lab to evaluate our
Minimum Viable Product with people who
had moderate to profound hearing loss
but we also wanted to know how people
would use live transcribe over time how
would it work in different environments
like in the home or in the classroom and
what people's needs change with
continued use so to answer these
questions we partnered with Gallaudet
University the world's premier
university for the deaf and hard of
hearing and that collaboration allowed
us to collect longitudinal feedback from
faculty and students who use live
transcribe in everyday life and after
iterating on our designs based on their
feedback and adding new functionality we
conducted a second lab based usability
study again with participants who had
moderate to profound hearing loss
okay so let's dig into those lab studies
a little bit our protocols started with
questions like tell me about a time when
you use real-time captioning what did
you like about the experience and what
did you dislike about the experience so
background questions helped us
understand previous experiences as well
as current knee
then we enabled the prototype and we
handed it to the participant and for the
next 60 minutes we initiated
conversation about a variety of topics
and generally observed how the
participants interacted with the phone
we also evaluated different text flows
and probed for feedback on the visual
design so in our prototype white
italicized text signified unfine alized
text whereas yellow normal text
represented finalized text did these
participants understand that color and
type forum indicated confidence in the
transcription and was that information
even valuable so it was in this research
that we learned that changing the type
form and text color actually distracted
participants from the conversation
additionally our participants
self-reported that italics made reading
more difficult for them and these
insights were reinforced by previous
research in this space which says that
transcript is easiest to read when it's
not layered with these extra signals we
also learned that our original scrolling
text flow felt natural unlike the other
flows that we showed participants it
didn't force them to shift their eyes to
another part of the screen so because of
these insights we removed those
colourful confidence levels we used a
normal type form instead of an italic
type form and we proceeded with the
scrolling text flow and this is just the
beginning we'll continue to make
improvements as we conduct further
research but what I really hope to show
today is the power of empathy so by
putting aside our own assumptions about
the visual design and conducting
research with our target audience we
changed the product design to be more
legible and ultimately accessible and
next up is Loren here to talk to us
about dexterity thanks Melissa hi
everyone my name is Lauren and I'm a
software engineer on central
accessibility now let's talk a little
bit about dexterity the challenges users
with dexterity impairments space and the
services on Android to help with these
challenges
according to the US Census more than 50
million people or more than 19 percent
of the US population has some form of
mobility impairment more so in the u.s.
more than 2 million of these people have
an impairment that impacts how
understandable their speeches over 15
million people have limited dexterity in
their hands and nearly 20 million people
have difficulty lifting and grasping the
majority of this population is over 65
years old those with severe dexterity
challenges include those with conditions
such as ALS cerebral palsy Parkinson's
or spinal cord injuries some conditions
result in users experiencing involuntary
movements such as spasms and tremors
they may also have difficulties with
speech and having their speech
understood many conditions impacting the
Xterra TR progressive as loss of
dexterity happens fine motor skills may
regress people might have difficulty
with picking things up or maintaining a
hold on items grasping or interacting
with a phone can be particularly
challenging for people within this
population there are varying levels of
severity of dexterity impairments and we
offer various apps and services on
Android that can be used to help users
based on their own individual needs we
introduced accessibility menu last year
designed to make common interactions
easier for people with dexterity
challenges accessibility many years
simplifies common actions such as power
off locking the screen and accessing
notifications and recent apps when
enabled it can be opened via a button at
the bottom of the screen which helps
those with limited reach now we're
adding new controls for volume and
brightness so the user can continuously
adjust volume and brightness without
leaving the menu we've also added an
option for large buttons in settings to
make them any buttons larger so those
that may have more limited hand
dexterity can use voice access to
control their phone via voice voice
access uses voice commands to perform
gestures on elements on the screen
without needing to physically touch the
phone voice access was recently launched
in September of last year you can
download it now at G Cove slash voice
access
voice access places an overlay of
numbers over the actionable elements on
the screen simply speak to your phone
with actions such as click seven or go
back to interact with your phone when
voice access is enabled you can continue
using your usual google assistant
commands such as setting a timer or
checking the weather a feedback bar is
always present at the top of the screen
that captures your spoken phrases you
can specifically refer to elements by
their numbers such as top seven or you
can refer to the name of the elements so
if you wanted to open an app or you want
to open Google keep you could say open
keep we're also happy to announce that
we brought support to French Italian
German and Spanish so voice access is
great for those with limited hand
dexterity and understandable speech but
there's many out there who may not be
able to speak clearly
for those Android users we have switch
access switch access allows users with
limited hand dexterity and limited
speech to navigate through their phone
using external buttons or switches I'll
show you what a typical switch might
look like
so a typical switch could look something
like this with two large buttons and a
user can interact with a switch with
their hands or if they have more control
in other parts of their body they may
use another part of their party body
such as their feet in a comment to
switch case one switch can be likened to
a tab that moves the highlight on the
screen when pressed while a second
switch can be thought of as an enter
that selects the highlighted item when
pressed switches can be configured to
meet user needs and switch access can be
used with as little as one switch most
input devices work with switch access
including just a regular USB keyboard so
text editing is commonly a pain point
for switch users so we recently added
text editing menus these menus add
shortcuts for previously time-consuming
text editing tasks such as highlighting
in the leading text undoing or redoing
actions copy cut and paste this allows
text editing to be done much more
quickly and with the use of as little as
one switch I'll show a quick demo of
this
okay so in this demo I'm using switches
configured to the volume keys assigning
switches to the volume keys is a very
easy way for developers to test out
switch access on their own apps without
needing to have an external switch so
using the volume keys I'm going to go
through the elements on this screen
until I get to the text field I wish to
edit I can select the text field and it
brings up our text many years so I want
to move a word around so I will go to
highlight and then choose the
granularity that I wish to highlight so
I'll choose highlight previous words
which highlights this word peaches here
then I can cut the word with the menu
and then now I want to paste the word
somewhere else so to do this I first
need to move the cursor so I can go to
previous and then I'll do previous lines
to move to the beginning of this text
field and then I can paste the word
there but what if I made a mistake
we have undo and redo actions added to
these many years text editing mistakes
can be very costly for switch users so
these actions allow our users to go more
quickly back to text editing and then
now I'll go back to the slides
so switching gears let's talk a little
bit about what's new for vision to start
with here's a little bit of background
on this population according to the
World Health Organization it's estimated
that 253 million people globally live
with moderate to severe visual
impairment and people over 50 are most
at risk 36 million of these people are
blind we're here to help people with
vision loss be able to access and enjoy
not just their phones but the world
around them
lookout is an Android app that helps
make the real world accessible for
people who are blind or low vision by
helping them complete tasks and routines
more independently we launched lookout
in March of this year now I'll show a
quick video that speaks a little more to
what lookout does and how it's used by
our users person definitely need
someone's help to pick out matching
socks a lot of times my daughter picks
them out
love you Thomas future the goal is to be
less disruptive to that routine that
they're engaged in Patrick Clary product
manager on Google accessibility for
anyone with any type of impairment or a
disability there's a strive for
independence and I think this is
actually just human nature you're
relying more on other people to drive
you around or help you accomplish
certain things it can be frustrating
with lookout we had been talking to many
different users with vision impairments
and we knew that there was a need to
provide them with more independence with
daily routines if you're using a lookout
for the first time basically you open it
up and you can just start pointing it at
things and it will start telling you
about the space around you would you
like some coffee
it'll tell you about objects and it can
also detect things like bar code
I mean it all feels the same sir it
seems it happened today I couldn't have
dreamed about you know I dreamed for
phones to be talking they are talking I
dreamed for ability to navigate
we can do that today artificial
intelligence it's gonna play a major
role in the lives of people with
disabilities and in the case of lookout
it's going to be able to provide these
users with an understanding of the space
surrounding
so as you saw in that video lookout is
able to detect and recognize a variety
of objects including currency and text
through computer vision and machine
learning
lookout uses several image classifiers
that run continuously on the device
this allows lookout to process video and
provide results to users in near real
time since information is processed on
device Lookout can even work in airplane
mode results are also scored based on a
variety of signals including user
context our goal is to provide the most
relevant results to users in a timely
manner
lookout contains three modes Explorer
shopping and quick read that allows
users to further contextualize their
environment and what type of information
they want out of it Explorer is the most
widespread mode that can be used for a
variety of daily routines such as
cleaning the house cooking dinner or
visiting a new space for the first time
shopping includes on device bar code
lookup as well as currency detection
quick read focuses on text and can be
used for activities such as going
through the mail or reading labels on
items in the kitchen here's a quote from
one of our users I use lookout once in
preparation for making spaghetti it very
accurately describes each item without
me having to maneuver the device or
struggle to get the items in focus
finding the correct ingredients to use
when cooking is something that many
sighted users hardly think about this
shows how lookout can be used to really
change lives by healthy helping people
who are blind or low vision be more
independent you can find lookout on
Google Play at Chico slash lookout app
it's available in the US and it was
initially launched on pixel and we're
happy to announce that lookout is
expanding to Samsung S 8 through S 10
and LG g7 and g8 devices supports these
new devices is rolling out now we want
to get lookout in the hands of as many
users as possible so we anticipate
releasing lookout on more devices
throughout the year now I'll hand it off
to Kelly to talk a little bit more about
what else is new and vision
[Applause]
hello everyone my name is Kelly Chang
and a program manager from kukup exiting
and passing Taiwan let's talk about how
to make a phone accessible for polite
and your vision users talkback
it's a enjoy screen reader we provide a
spoken feedback so let who are blind or
have difficulty they can use their phone
without you without a look looking at a
screen topic can read us on screen
reader loudly and then users to interact
with their devices by gestures before we
jump into our new feature I want you to
think about something what will you do
to fight the movie details like what
Tyler movie start at the cinema you can
never get it easily on your phone and
it's simple for you now imagine that how
difficult this would be if if you
couldn't see on the screen not so easy
right today we are going to give
everyone a better user journey in your
screen reader to help you find your
navigate and find your content quickly
people who cannot see well they need to
swipe one element at a time to let a
screen reader to lure the problem and
you want if you want to find the things
they may need to do a lot of gestures
that's why we enhance the screen search
feature so we provide a user interface
to perform a search and it can be
triggered by not only keyboard shortcuts
but also by touch gestures and the voice
input less more it provides any
languages supported by Android
and it's always available you you can
use it in accessibility suite 7.3 now ok
lights I have a live demo okay that's a
you are curious that roarin shall talk
about loss switch SS so you want to
learn more so let's see how he works in
tall back without search talkback on
Chrome and just listen
how many straps i doing connectionists
ht1 open tap more options products and
features google logo collapse open the
accessibility products and feature
explore some of goop product sources
accessibility accessibility get started
with an android OS from hearing aid to
android access switch access help link
double tap to activate see it takes like
10 or 20 swaps and then you can imagine
light if the link at the bottom so we
may need is a swap more than 30 or 40
times now with such feature it becomes
super easy let's try it
so to start search swap let land down
expand Roy OS type search term showing
English us QWERTY keyboard research
editing type search term edit box so it
will bring you to a search fake page
then let's switch lights tabular switch
but you may wonder how people with limit
either time-limited a site how they do
it but it's the same behavior you just
attach on a keyboard
really you listen that's what you want a
later you just lift your finger up then
either world works so let's do it
SS W by T selected switch CH to matches
and ELISA with matches will be showing
and then you can check which one you are
looking for
then double-click lays it away per unit
or details dicey the first one is witchy
Isis help is they exactly what you want
and then you go it clear and switch
access switch access help link chrome
get started with accessibility scanner
only DoubleTap to activate it's that
simple so we the purpose we get a user
Tula place faster and to make people
more productive and efficiency ok let's
go back to lost lights ducting this is
one of my favorite feature you know why
because when I impaired using my phone
in low-light conditions and I believe a
lot of you may have this kind of
experience and it make it easier for you
use your phone like really and browse
the phone easily and it's either helpful
for people who are sensitive to light or
they have low vision so it's a session
wired up thing and you can find the
options under settings and you can find
out accessibility and the display it's
come young enjoy a cube and it also
saves your battery life now let's talk
about not just vision but all kinds of
disabilities lights try on if you want
to change your volume so you click on
your value button and there's a right
side of the screen shine you can see
there's a control panel so it will show
only for a few seconds and you imagine
like if you people with physical
impairments our limited asides they may
not get enough time to do it so that
accessibility timeouts it's a new
feature we give us a little extra time
to interact with their devices we hope
you people to find a way and you can
change your time on the accessibility
settings so let mega people
- it's more efficient what app developer
would need to do is later useless
accessibility manager yang together
becoming the tire and the follow Laval
you do works and this is also coming in
NGO eq we will have diff type sections
and tomorrow so you are welcome to join
us
so let's hand it over to Brian for a
summary thank you thank you thank you
Kelly Thank You Melissa Thank You Lauren
Thank You Creative Lab on today we
talked about our mission of making our
products and the real world more
universally accessible we dove into the
curb cut effect to drive home how
important and what the wonderful
unintended consequences of building for
accessibility can be I spoke a little
bit about Android and how now with our
smartphone it you are able to caption
both the real world and almost all of
the content on the device no other
operating system in the world can make
that can make that claim Melissa did a
wonderful job at describing and
demonstrating the before and after of
how we use her research to inform our
decisions and really upend our own
biases and make informed decisions based
on data lauren demonstrated voice access
and switch access that innovative way to
use a two-button keyboard I think that
is so cool that you can text edit with
two buttons it's just awesome Kelly
talked about talkback dark-themed and
all of these wonderful new products that
we have for vision so I'm not gonna keep
you guys any any longer but I want to
let you know about a couple of other
talks including one today that we're
going to do on accessible audio on
Android at five pm on stage seven so if
you want to dive in on the audio topic
we'll be talking about audio
it's gonna be really cool we'll do a
hearing loss simulation tomorrow we're
gonna have it talk on des mystifying
accessibility development on Android
that's targeted toward developers and
then lastly we have two accessibility
related experiments tent one the
experiments sandbox and the other the
accessibility sandbox so everybody thank
you so much for coming today thank you
for your interest in accessibility and
we hope you have a blast at i/o
[Music]